from a guy's point of view why don't you
think have you ever had any
men in a toxic relationship where they
don't leave and why don't you think they
leave
control
um
yeah
i think it just boils down to control
um 100 because of
i know a few friends who've been
you've been the aggressor in
relationships and there's literally no
reason why you're there because you're
never home you're cheating on your
partner you're being your partner you're
beating your kids but you you stay
because you want you just want control i
feel like it's down to control
um you want control what do you mean so
so the girl was beating him or the other
no no the other way around so the guy
was the aggressor okay the guy was the
aggressor and she stayed because she
wants control oh why the lady why why
the woman standing yeah like oh right
i i'm not like have you ever had a guy
friend that that's happened to oh okay
because johnny depp was in a
relationship with her for like years
this was going on
so i'm just curious if you have any male
friends maybe not to that extent but
something like that's happened too
no no no i mean i've been well my last
ex was pretty like all relations was
pretty toxic i don't have i don't know
if i have any friends that have been in
a relationship
um well
toxic was like
i didn't want to like it got so bad to a
point where like i didn't want to be
seen in like public with her because
it's like i go to no no it really got
that bad because what happened was when
we first started dating it was sweet you
know the honeymoon stage and it was like
so [ __ ] sunshine and giggles that's
how she got me
um
and then we got to like we got together
and she um we used to go to my like a
local bar and you know just hang out
after work you know just catch up and
stuff like that and she and then after
it got so bad to a point where like she
screwed like started screaming arguing
in public like
i understand one thing at home and like
it's one thing right but like when i
have to look right around
when she's going to the bathroom or
she's going to order a drink or
something and people are turning around
with like
like one of those is it's bad and then i
tried to explain it to her but she's in
her little world like oh no no no and i
was listening there was a camera next to
you and i showed you that how many
people like you know i mean and for
example like if you keep you disappear i
told her straight up if you keep this up
right one of these days we're going to
be walking down the street right you're
going to give some smirky guy or some
small some girl like a look or something
i'll say something snarky she's going to
slap you in the face you're going to be
on the floor and i'm not going to help
you i'm going to look at the guy or the
girl be like listen you just proved my
point and shake his hand and keep it
stepping right because honestly like it
got really bad like is this is it to a
point when
we broke up but i broke it off with her
like after like seriously because i was
the type of i was an optimist thinking
that like she might change
like you know keep dragging i dragged
out for 11 months i dragged it out were
you trying to fix her
no i want to say fixer just like
give a helpful advice
you know what yeah [ __ ] that she's my
yes i was trying to fix her because the
[ __ ] was crazy
i'm sorry the [ __ ] was crazy
like we couldn't go 15 minutes without
having an argument put it too that way
like it was bad but i think it might
also be that hope that the person might
change yeah and also like emotional
dependency on the person and complacency
like once you're so used to someone and
then they kind of act up i feel like
you're more okay with staying and
tolerating it than just
instantly leaving i'm not gonna lie i
told i told people if she gets how many
was it 30
40 or 50 subs i'll get i'll get my ex on
the show and then
yeah
so guys listen did you say thirty
thousand i said no no no no no no no
thirty was it fifty or sixty by the end
of next month yeah i'll try getting my
eggs on the show so guys yeah if you
subscribe hit the subscribe button right
now oh yeah fifty thousand no fifty to
sixty fifty or sixty we'll discuss it on
camera
cameras
we'll go 60 yeah i'm i'm the one getting
roasted here 60 000 subs he'll bring his
toxic acts on the show and i'll
interview them
ask her why she was so crazy
but i'll be like
what
be like why were you insane
just just or not honestly bro just blunt
it out like yeah like what's wrong with
you
like what if she what if she says you
were the problem
okay cool
no that's exactly what you're gonna say
i know her because everything everything
she everything that i've done for her or
anything any problems that i wrote
should blame me
like she got so bad like you literally
you know like in front of your parents
right like if you swear to your parents
you'll get like a backhander something
like you know i mean i don't swear in
front of my parents we went and had a
beach day lovely beach day we you know
we'll come back on the train and if she
didn't like we was having a conversation
she would disagree she started swearing
from eighteen in front of my mom and my
grandma brother like you don't do that
thing like like read the room yeah it
was bad
so yeah 66 60 000 subs guys
i might hit that soon you know what if
you listen if you do cool i'm gonna hit
her up on something like you do but the
thing is like listen i'll reach out if
she wants to come and do the show that's
fine if you don't you can't blame me i
tried
okay
um what about you any stories yeah i was
gonna say like i've seen situations
where like
the girls like you say that you say the
guy's whipped because he's like
oh yeah yeah come out let's like link up
and do something
nah i can't because i'm with my girl and
that
and like
he's just like the girl's like not being
like controlling but like
she's like bet she's like rude to him
and stuff like
and like he's just taking it i feel like
yeah
that's that's a situation where i've
seen like a toxic relationship
but like
i feel like people stay in certain toxic
relationships because they've got like
that if you've got a child now it's like
you you've got to try and make it work
or
if you get married quick let's say
you've only noticed about two years you
get married you've got to sort of stay
of that person or now you live together
it's like you
when you've got other things alongside
the relationships that are
you can't just
you can't just drop the relationship now
because i mean it's not just you two
liking each other
like it's deeper than that so
like that's why they stay so you think
it's like they're in too deep like they
don't really know she's crazy and then
they get in so deeply
at first everybody sorry at first every
relationship's good like
at the start
every you wouldn't be in the
relationship if it was if you saw the
red flag straight away or if you like
if you didn't enjoy it at first you're
not going to be in that relationship so
it always the first part of the
relationship's always the best because
you're getting to know each other you're
having the most fun you're trying to
like impress each other
and then as it goes on that's when the
problems you'll see like the red flags
more clearly and you
you like that's when the problems start
occurring yeah that no no one's a if if
if you jump into a relationship and the
guy slaps you on the first date
are you gonna marry this guy you're not
so
he's gonna be really friendly and then
he's gonna be more possessive and it's
gonna it's gonna gradually increase to
him being abusive or whatever that's why
but do you think that comes with like an
insecurity like he doesn't want no one
else to have you or any type of thing
because control does have a big effect
on a relationship whether it's like a
small scale or not and it's like how do
you see that from the start like how do
you kind of gauge those kind of red
flags from the beginning like it's
really hard i was gonna say um has uh
it's probably an old tv program it's
based on a true event right have you
ever seen a murder by my boyfriend yeah
sorry that's crazy yeah
so basically for
you guys have you seen it um
some people haven't seen it basically in
another show
he so the girl starts dating this guy
everything everything goes good you have
a kid but then after that you know he
starts like
getting possessed possessive wouldn't
let her out the house and then he get he
goes and gets another girlfriend
while he's with her when the kid she
goes to um
to find out where she lives next thing
you know he goes into a store where she
works
black and blue differently and then yeah
man like so that's probably like the
perfect program to describe
like it's sad because it starts off
great and it ends up with him killing
her with a ironing board yeah
[Music]
based on true story wow
there's a song there's a song similar to
that have you heard uh leslie by dave
talks about like domestic violence
he just talks about like how the girl it
was all perfect like rainbow sunshine
and then it's just like it's a gradual
thing it's not suddenly he just attacks
you of nowhere psych
it's like don't ignore the red yeah yeah
don't ignore the little signs like yeah
you just can't
because at the end of the day everybody
has the right to leave
you know do you do you get what do you
think is worse being a physically
emotionally
i always say emotionally abused
both of them together at the same time
scars will heal scar the emotion is
called that's for life
i always say i would rather someone slap
me
than to say something that would happen
for the rest of my life because i
exactly
want to repeat
in relationships play fighting is like
very dangerous because if a guy gets too
comfortable even a girl gets too
comfortable like with hitting you
um then suddenly when they actually do
hit you once they're mad they don't see
it as that bad yeah
like what happened to me in my past
relationship like the guy used to just
like hit me for fun like play fighting
in the beginning i was kind of like whoa
like but then it got like more and more
and more and i would have like bruises
on my arms and [ __ ] he would grab me as
well and he would just see it as oh no
i'm just playing with you i'm like bro
don't you see my arms especially because
my skin is lighter right so you can
really see it so what why did why why
would you like leave then why didn't you
you know i mean
because i was dumb like listen i was in
in that relationship i feel like i was
in a way like emotionally dependent on
him and he manipulated me to the point
where i was actually there while he was
doing the craziness and i was still
there like the tip of the iceberg was
when we had broken up and we hadn't been
together for probably like eight months
and he came to my house and he just
smashed my door like i had a huge hole
in my door because he heard a guy inside
my house i was on facetime with a guy
he smashed my door
crazy and he thought he didn't think of
it as